video of a wild and destructive ride by
a U-Haul truck in Brooklyn New York that
killed one person and injured eight
others one surveillance video shows the
truck ramming into someone who was on a
moped yesterday another shows a
pedestrian diving out of the way as the
suspect drove onto the sidewalk with
police in Pursuit after nearly an hour a
cruiser pinned the vehicle against a
building and officers arrested
62-year-old Wang soar he has a history
of violence and mental illness soar
rented the truck in Florida two weeks
ago and law enforcement says that he may
have been living in his vehicle his son
told the Associated Press quote very
frequently he'll choose to skip out on
his medications and do something like
this